john i think you know you look cool huh
and you do oh oh my god
so cool you know
so cool i was throwing my hair out just
for this specifically dude my god
guys look at us we got two witcher
reactions this week because we're trying
to catch up before season two premieres
long time spider-man no home is gonna be
a busy week
anyway
guys episode seven of season one excited
to see how this goes down geralt
jennifer trying to have a d to
toss the fruit of your lines to your
witcher
yeah
every episode we need a new update on
the team running out of words
all right guys hit that like button
smash that freaking uh subscribe nope
it's reverse you guys know i'm gay yeah
bull like to watch the longest receiver
with the time code for wichity which
which are over at patron uh cover a
bunch of shows over there as well
lastly thanks to the boys of prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
especially if there is inappropriate
content that they gotta blur you guys
are good at that and let's get to it
you need to be careful child
this place isn't safe if you're alone
and it's the same as every other place
not exactly you're talking real
generalizations
[Laughter]
what a barren wasteland what a grand
canyon
what job did you take on now witcher
slaying the greatest monster of all
man
you've come for your child of surprise
haven't you the officer
i want you to tell me that he's safe and
healthy so i can keep on riding he is a
girl
yes operation
[Laughter]
why do you think she's not
safe i saw an army making camp at the
ammo pass
a sea of black and gold
black and yellow black and yellow
scent assassins
what
were you fired
no
wow so he did protect her yeah
[Music]
this mouse can't live i mean yeah
i'm like we're in the timeline aren't we
that's good that's the real mousex
sweet
let's go people
i've been away 12 years and i planned on
staying that way
till you send aid meant to kill me
ah
do not do this if you treated me more
like a friend than a threat
do you know
the difference anymore
my feelings are hurt
give her to me call it destiny security
what larger force is at work i don't
care
i will take her
protect her
and bring her back unharmed i promise
you oh so we've caught up to like near
the first episode yeah okay
if siri survives then pavetta lives on
too
that lineage man
all important
who needs you
those people notice her
[Music]
where do you get a piece like this
that was my mother's
you buy a thousand pairs of gloves with
a piece like this we've got a sight more
than you do roof
food
space on the floor to sleep a lot's
happening on this continent but we're
safer when we stick together so that
woman's gonna die this episode
absolutely or turn into something
horrible
[Music]
okay she's gonna get jacked
pleased to meet you princess
i'll summon you when she's ready
that's not the same girl right is this a
decoy yeah okay i was like have i been
totally misreading this
okay
i have to go what no
take care
[Music]
what a detail damn yeah got nipple
chills from that she needs family
you know nothing about that
your own mother cared so little she
discarded you
you lecture me on a mother's love yet
offer up someone else's daughter
i need your promise you won't come back
if i hear siri's in danger
you know i can't do that
dude is gerald's still there
she's been here this whole
time like oh god maybe i don't know oh
this is so clever it actually really
works when you know the outcome
it makes it that much more intense
no [ __ ] oh look who's back
sometimes boring is better
hmm
dude in front of everyone yeah
everyone stop what you're doing
and it was fun
we wanted
the object of desire
after where i came from i lapped it up i
know how you feel
[Laughter]
where's sarah
desai can wait fine i'll just follow the
sign of crying girls
she has no idea you're here
oh
god i remember that episode yeah feels
like forever a good stop cry
for the record i get that the aging
properties for these characters are not
the same as regular pigments
for all you guys are accomplishing that
magic and whatnot look i'm levitating
masala whatever you lack in talent you
make up for incompetence she doesn't
need confidence her father owns off of
craden so he could have 100 horses for
her spot here
these women are tripping balls man
you know if they
catch us they really will expel there
are far worse things than expulsion
like what
artusa went corporate man
it's gonna be a tuition scandal soon
i've got so many questions
you want to know more
yes yeah that's what she means by
questions
[Laughter]
the ability to create life
real life
they take that from you
i don't care what you do but remember
this
even if you do everything right
follow their rules that's still no
guarantee you'll get what you want
enough
back to your rooms girls
oh [ __ ]
an emergency conclave of the northern
mages
nilfgaard took maradona what they're
attacking sintra
all those years of swinging his sword
around for years he wasn't serving as a
mage
or killing babies born at an eclipse
we believe in shared sacrifice you also
believe in forbidden magic demonology
necromancy fire magic forbidden magic is
one of the ghost stories taught to us
here there is no such thing as dark or
light magic magic is magic
huh
we know that if we take cintra we have a
chance of saving it
if you won't take sides
then at least stay out of our way
buddy is still there
just been meditating all this time
we have called them a lost cause for
years
but we stop trying to
and it is time now that we risk not only
our lives but our pride
and try again
the show's so good
this is so good right now this is so
damn good
if nilfgaard wins
that's why velga forts and i and some
others are going to fight you should
join us why would i protect this
if you will not do it for the
brotherhood
then do it for me
i'm not vulnerable here
power
desperation have you ever used that word
before
[Laughter]
that great response
[Music]
dude god he was there the whole time
you think hilanthi would know he was
down there right yeah i think she'd want
him maybe unleashed at some point
if i can bring him here
to siri destiny may yet side with us
[Music]
wild
it's time
wait where are you going
uh so they did try to bring him to her
okay because i remember her being like
go find geralt
[Music]
so much for destiny
yeah
he's gone
looks like he's escaped that's what they
were whispering
he is your destiny
he's probably outside somewhere
man this show must be [ __ ] awesome on
a re-watch huh yeah
you really know the geography of time
and event
dang
oh they're looking for each other
cool ass [ __ ] show
oh
damn good
so close
right there know
ships in the night
tell me what i want to know and you'll
live
you just missed her man nice you just
missed it
she's so much further away
i was like maybe girls is chilling in
the cabin somewhere yeah
nope
he's just out there in the weeds looking
around for clues
i think those are the people who notice
her
you made it out you're all right i told
you it was her at the market
only thing special about you was the
[ __ ] crown on your head
[Music]
verily i say unto you the era of the
sword and the axe is mine
the wolf chill on the white light is
mine
the time of madness and the time of
contempt
dammit christ
that is going to be a season finale boy
dude it was dope that was legitimate
that was so cool it was that finale
an hour okay awesome good morning that's
what i'm talking about give me that hour
give me that
give me that hour and ten
oh man what a show what a show dude i'm
really loving this i keep talking about
it with people yeah this is spiderman
topics and conversations these days
uh yeah like i'm so late we're so late
to catch a witcher and uh when i discuss
it i tell people like yeah the first
episode's a little bit rough because
there's a lot to wrap your head around
and uh you know some like but it really
starts to form like more of a
personality and a life as it progresses
quickly like my episode two i remember
really liking like liking the hell out
of a lot and then like quickly growing
to love the show
um
but then you watch this
that ties it all back to episode one and
you're like damn if someone's got a [ __ ]
done better they got like so much better
all of a sudden yeah yeah like that
because it wasn't like so much to
process that first time and feeling and
that happened i remember that feeling of
of um
i felt like we just watched like some
season finale of something
because there's so much context we don't
have yeah and then for the patience to
pay off as as the build-up happens
and then you get to you know the the
prelude to the events uh from geralt's
perspective
leading into the fall of sintra
wow it's it's it makes it more intense
knowing that it's going to collapse and
then it makes it more exciting watching
the puzzle pieces come together and
watching different perk because i do
remember that moment of
of us uh cirilla playing
playing the game with those guys
and then looking over and stuff like i
remembered all that so to see if i
didn't watch the perspectives like wow
this is such a well thought out show
yeah that's like usually you only see
that usually in movies but that's like a
two to three hour piece to do that with
a series where you're like okay by
episode seven then we're gonna go back
yeah wow that's a lot to think ahead on
my god
yeah and i mean i'm sure that rewards
the binge watching experience but even
just watching week to week like it feels
rewarding then to to go back and yeah
see that difference in perspective and
you meet the show
and siri especially
from their perspective you know as
they're being attacked and even though
you know like kalanthi is all-powerful
and very confident you know you're in
more of the victim position at the start
and now to see
the events that led to this and like
everybody at uh oh god you know eratusa
there you go everybody eretza like
arguing as to whether or not to
intervene and like just all the
different points of no return and then
yeah seeing as she locks up geralt and
placing him you know geographically in
time in that event like
yeah it felt like really natural care uh
story development but also like a really
cool like clever way to tie it all back
around they really make the timeline
thing work to greater effect
a common complaint that i actually have
with a lot of tv shows
uh especially when like a season ends
and then a new one starts is i often
can't i have a difficult time getting on
board with a lot of character
development that happened off-screen
because i do major time jumps yeah and i
usually i'm like well you're a show i
want to feel that i want to see it and
somehow this show manages to be the the
one that makes it work almost episode
episode
like it's not even like a season break
and i'm like oh man should i
see that i guess it's because it's part
of the structure it's like ingrained
into it the time jumps
and so it doesn't make me feel like i
missed out on something yeah exactly or
um or like this would be better with
more context yeah or without seeing more
of the process like we just start off
here and it just hops ahead 12 years for
a geralt's story
and then it takes a little time to go oh
[ __ ] okay we've we're caught up to
episode one
and
whatever happened there is yet i don't
it doesn't bother me you know like it
really does work effectively
um i do i'm curious though because i
think the use of flashbacks was used
incredibly well and i i especially
preferred it when it was like uh
you know i think anime often does it a
lot where they use flashbacks and then
when you when you get more context the
flashbacks when you you re-experience
them they work in a different context
suddenly like you'd see revisit the same
scene but it just feels entirely
different now that you have more of an
expanded knowledge upon it all
and then some of the flashbacks like
some of the whispering dialogue moments
you actually don't just see them whisper
you get to hear with her what they're
communicating to one another
uh the the only parts that were a little
bit
sometimes a little off to me were at the
times in eratusa with jennifer um
because i i go
we watch this week to week
but
on a binge i'm like how much of that was
truly necessary
for some of that with urges that i
didn't really think we were getting full
expansion but that's that's like the
most minor nitpick literally it's not a
problem because i still
did enjoy it uh all of our i enjoyed all
of that you know like this is
it's it's interesting of how this is
working on almost a meta level of
revisiting the past for these characters
because
it's
moving forward for
uh geralt's story to go to the past for
our experience of the first episode and
the beginning of uh cirilla story
cirilla yeah from cirillas story
and then
you're going with jennifer who's going
to the her actual past yes
uncovering stuff and then also seeing
the development of what's happened with
with the characters there it it it is
it makes it more compelling the way they
they navigate all this and and i thought
complementary wise too as much as there
were still fantasy elements in the first
episode that was arguably the the least
fantastical one of the episodes we've
seen so far that was the one that still
felt the most
grounded in in some form of reality was
you know some stuff with mages and you
know him fighting a beast at the
beginning of the episode
but it's still for the most part pretty
grounded in reality that didn't get that
fantastical
yeah it was more about the like almost
political implications of everything in
this one yeah and then chilling in
cintra and seeing what's going on there
and the battles and stuff and then this
episode brings it back to that like we
were talking about the way it's really
you know intimate close-up handheld it
felt less fantastical like right off the
bat so it was neat and then even when
you're cutting to yennefer and catching
up with
he looks like lenny kravitz
he does he does look like lenny crowd
yes oh no no i'm not going to be able to
unsee that like the now you're like with
the air and the beer like yeah straight
out of the lenny kravitz from hungary
he's going to dress her up in the next
episode but then yeah even going going
to that and then you know all this
development that you see i think it's
just the acting is so damn good too that
you could feel a lot of the
hiss the history of whatever we didn't
see is definitely there
like she's talking with
lenny kravitz whatever
one character i'm like god what was his
name she's talking with him about like
yeah you know i did all these guys i had
all this power and then he but it you
know it ultimately left me feeling
pretty empty and sucks
and
yeah you know i got enough of that from
actual episodes and i i believe you on
your experiences and i could feel it i
think that's the thing that i why the
time jumps work so well is because
whatever you don't see you can feel
those experiences regardless of not
having to actually have been there for
it this must be a fascinating show to
act on because you probably have to be
doing lots of homework for things that
have happened intervening time that we
don't get to see between episodes like
this week it's 30 years later so you
have 30 more years of life experiences
or whatever
um but yeah i i i would generally kind
of agree and jump on to everything you
just said and yeah i mean there is a
certain aspect of the stuff that takes
place in eratusa that is it's like out
of everything in the episode that is the
most directly focused i feel like on one
character because going back there is
such a big deal for yennefer and it
brings back so many traumatic
experiences
yeah and you've got her kind of getting
this catharsis
of being able to to speak her mind to
the cogs in the new machine basically
and she's like getting them all high and
stuff um and yeah it's like out of
everything in the episode that feels the
most zoomed in because most everything
else is sort of like looking at the big
chess board and looking at you know the
surrounding details of the yeah big
event that kicked off the season and
that at least gave us you know our main
sense
of this world and where everybody is
within it
um so yeah like there is a certain
aspect there where it does kind of feel
differently attuned than the rest of the
episode but even still i thought there
were so many great backs and forths and
like her and and to say uh
if i'm getting her name right about that
their back and forth is always really
great because especially the woman that
plays josiah like her
there's so much in her performance that
is constantly her like it to me always
appears like she's not going to say a
handful of things that she really wants
to say and she's going to keep poised
because she's always thinking of the
bigger picture and it's like yeah that
that whole bit about her being like her
deanna for being her best student and
it's like she doesn't even ever say that
to her it's just a second-hand piece of
information that that other maid uses to
get her there
um but yeah like i i if i can jump in
really fast i think the relationship's
so compelling because
at the end of the day yennefer is who
she is in large part due to her
so it's like this strained mentor-mentee
relationship that they have and neither
of them really can just talk to the
other no no no they're always playing
the game while they're talking and it's
so hard especially for especially for
jennifer to be any kind of vulnerable
in this place and i mean you feel i
think they do a nice job of drawing that
picture because
part of you can kind of see it from you
know the the
uh perspective of you know like the the
up and coming mages and things and the
excitement of that but you can also see
the intense
hurt and bitterness that comes out of
the experience
and they're good at doing that where
it's not like
for us as viewers like yeah completely
screw this place but also there's some
pretty nasty stuff that happens here
yeah i think she's showing them all the
eels and everything i'm like yeah this
is pretty nasty even still and then what
the correct like and you also seen the
what's happened with aratuza
in terms of like rich kids and uh yeah
yeah if anybody's got money you're
watching how like this is the kind of
[ __ ] that jennifer
knew was
not that she predicted it out you know
out loud or or even thought that would
be the thing that would happen but she
could see the capacity of the corruption
and how this is not what it's made out
to be yeah um it's like the leak of
shadows
the
the the the uh damn what was i gonna say
i liked what was popping in my head and
i forgot it it's gone it's gone forever
it's permanently gone it's never done
about geralt or was it about
jennifer i don't know it'll come oh
kalanthi yeah she you know she is such a
really hit me like we haven't
talked about just how [ __ ] great she
is she is
great no matter how brief the appearance
and whatever episode like she had like
she really does have that queen presence
where like the second she's back on
screen you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah man yeah like i love every time
we've gotten a check-in with her
was that the third episode we have of
her yeah there's always so much life
like she really feels like plucked out
of this period
and uh there's just constant you can
feel there's so much different thought
processes happening with her at once you
know it's she's a strong character very
strong yeah uh terrific actress and i
thought this episode this one had the
best clock to it because usually how
they have been has been is is they build
to sort of a a nice crescendo of watch
cutting around different
the timelines or events or something
like that they're usually like a build
up to like something like oh is it like
the fidelities of each episode has been
so intense when there's this just starts
like we got a clock yeah yeah and
everybody is just like oh yeah yeah and
everybody's bound to the to the
situation that's created it's just
everyone's debating left and right you
know yeah yeah there's not a component
of like we're gonna travel for a while
and then things are really gonna kick
off it's just like yeah the whole time
you're dealing with this big old
situation that's affecting you know the
entire continent and i think what's also
one of the rewarding aspects of the
series too like nilfgaard is such a
threat and i don't really know much
about that um
and i think one of the rewarding
elements of it is that would you because
it's a puzzle piece of story lines
converging
and when i think a big part of what
makes it even more enjoyable is when
you're like i'm getting it
yeah
you're like
yeah i'm understanding what's happening
yeah
that makes you feel good and really
rewarded for keeping track of all these
fantastical ideas places and people and
then the
the cyrilla character you know i i
actually find her more compelling when
she's just on her own yeah this is one
of her best episodes hands down i really
cared about her and there was a like
that this little nugget of a moment it's
because it's such a wide shot where
she's walking by and then
it's so brief where you know i thought
like maybe it's just background
characters who are over acting yeah
trying to get themselves in but you do
see that like the same people at the end
who approach her
um who do like pretty quickly look at
her and you see one guy point
and it's it's just happening and
it's like an easter egg of a shot
and and then i thought i was reading too
much into it because sometimes
background players try to do too much
moment in the sun
but it just goes to show just how
intentional that is and how if you just
really look it's like there's so much
happening but in this one little moment
if you just look you'll you'll see them
you'll see them looking at her and then
for it to come back around and the
unleash of power as well
and it really man that plays on your
frustration so much of like damn he was
there
the whole time and literally what
happened was it's it's that thing of
like you were there i was there i missed
you hey yeah
all it was
except the reverse
yeah because she does say um you know
obviously such a big you know catalyst
of a finale moment for uh kalanthi to
say go find geralt and then go on this
avenger to go search for him
and that and that whole sequence too of
of him breaking out and trying to find
her and then being whisked out of the
city like it it really did catch me up
in that feeling of you know like in real
life where you're like if you lose
something or you're looking for
something you're like i know it's close
and in these precious moments while [ __ ]
is hitting the fan like this is the best
chance i have it finding the thing
because the further you know in time we
get the further in distance we'll
probably get to and uh we're going to
show carol if it's just there here still
yeah yeah like oh [ __ ] he's just been
underground there the whole time
it's the hangover yeah
yes
what i mean to it like going back to
siri like it it made me think of like
on the one hand it's unfortunate that
she decided to go off on her own and get
jumped but at the same time i was like
look good for that woman because like i
doubt she would have been able to
protect her from this you know ambush
here from these people and so like those
kinds of consequences and those kinds of
choices i feel like they're good at
making the weight ring
so it's like this would have been ugly
either way and i guess it's just less
ugly because she decided to go off alone
well it's really
cool what they did with cintra because
they
the first you you put it in the first
episode and they're such a focal point
and you're locked into the perspective
of the hierarchy of the the king queen
princess
and
you know they look like the the the
beloved kingdom and then as the show has
gone on the people there don't like to
be in there the mages don't like no one
likes them
yeah that's just what we
that's as the show has been going you
did the veneers just slowly spieled away
to the point where they're even debating
them like [ __ ] intro
and then that kind of confronts like the
fact that you yeah you it's like you uh
i don't know what the exact way the
phrase it is but you know it's like you
think of cintra and you have so many
kind of focal characters and series one
of your protagonists so you're like you
have a sympathetic eye towards sintra
and then to see it from this perspective
i think that makes just the sort of
political quality of the show ring truer
now because it's like we love siri and
we're rooting for siri except she comes
from this place that everybody hates and
that probably wasn't a very good place
in the grand scheme of things yeah you
know which is a fascinating little thing
because then she is eventually going to
have to confront that and she's probably
going to have to confront the reality of
who kalanthi really was and the good and
the bad of that and well then geralt's
yennefer can raise her together right
they can become the family we've always
wanted and i think also i mean we
touched on this in the last episode but
i thought this episode shed even more
light on it of yennefer wanting to be a
mom and and
like the last one really touched on that
they stripped her of a choice but
also it this one really showed how that
that's that strip of you know not being
able to have a child
creates
a um a dependency
that i'm sorry i'm watching my cat and
i'm so worried he's going to step on the
the power strip and just turn everything
off because that has happened before
yeah when she's talking about how they
make this this is a form of control that
they make you dependent on them yeah
this is your only family at this point
yeah i'm like i never realized
so does that happen to all them uh all
of them can't have kids i thought i
thought that was a sacrifice she made to
get her looks
no i mean i feel like i i feel like
that's part of the the whole ritual is
like if you make it to this point and
you don't get turned into an eel then
we're gonna put you through this ritual
where because something about that
seemed to me like it it part of it is
that it makes you look ideal but also
i'm sure there's something else about it
that like solidifies your magic
abilities and they also didn't prepare
her for the surgery properly yeah yeah
that's a big part of it like she had to
endure it under all pain yeah so it
seems like just if you're going to
ascend and and you know
pass basically if you're going to you
know complete this training and become a
mage you are going to give up that part
of yourself it's just to me yeah to me
it just read like everybody does that
okay yeah
all right guys well that was an amazing
episode i love the hell out of it uh
this is just been freaking i'm already
excited for season two
uh it's been a hell of a ride and then
we'll be here on time for season two
guys thanks for watching subscribe click
that bell hit that like button and we'll
see you for the finale of season one